allô allô françois oui c'est quasi mi
temps là là ça va mal très mal oui il
faut que tu viennes immédiatement dans
ma maison c'est très grave oui vient
bien avec julie et du snav a tout de
suite terminé
vous tombait mal ça ne va pas du tout
mais alors pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
mais que font-ils à il devrait déjà être
là
casimir mais voilà j'ai couru le plus
vite possible que ce parce qu'ils ne
commencent eux d'expliquer lorsqu'on les
autres seront là mais ça ne saurait
tarder ils vont arriver d'une seconde à
l'autre voilà les voilà de secourir
grave je viens de m'apercevoir que je
n'avais presque pas de meubles à ma
maison est vide alors je voudrais que
vous m'aidiez à nommer quoi et c'est
pour ça tu nous a fait courir comme des
fous casimir tu es vraiment incorrigible
bon alors de quoi tu besoin mehmet mais
de tout regarder je n'ai rien évidemment
nous pourrions peut-être apporter à
casimir chacun quelques meubles
provenant de chez nous oui moi j'accepte
avec joie c'est vrai mais vous pourriez
ça va merci mr sûrs
je savais que je pouvais compter sur ses
normes étaient
bouleversés écoutez je vais cacher mon
émotion la gueule
1 pendant ce temps-là meublé bien la
maison un
au revoir ils sont vraiment sympas n'est
ce pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh ben ça y est
nous voilà à pied d'oeuvre nous l'avons
vu qu'à installer nos meubles dans la
maison de casimir moi je lui apporte les
meubles de la salle à manger de mon
arrière arrière arrière grand mère et
moi des meubles de cuisine comme je me
dépossède en sa faveur de quelques
merveilles besoin de mon [ __ ]
attendant si j'aurai plus de place pour
les bibelots
une petite seconde mes amis il faut
d'abord savoir comment nous allons
disposer les meubles
trouve un peu quand même au petit
bonheur la chance non on va charmer non
je regrette mais il faut un minimum
d'organisation du jour c'est que
conseillez-vous si nous mettions la
salle à manger ici la liste au pourquoi
pas un peu plus loin là bas carrément
par là bas vous voyez nom je m'incline
chemin king devenait mais
aussi doucement tout d'abord doucement
parce que c'est vrai qu'elle est très
très ancienne jamais deux belles
semaines mois suivez-moi tuez-moi
aménage précaution alors voilà voilà
et bien la cuisinière de série club la
donner mais n'est apportée la cuisinière
attention ce mouvement a logiquement à
les élus
l'artiste unis si les chinois ne fait
pas semblant de porter je vous en prie
ces rames us que zélandais je commence à
avoir mal aux reins or
les livres oliver fisher wii a permis au
bout de ma bibliothèque je
ne sais pas le bon marché pour aller
c'est le le soutien ici ont faim mais
s'ils disent nos
fans je tiens beaucoup comme vous avez
tort parce qu'avec casimir ne va pas
faire long feu de votre fauteuil repas
de fin j'ai apporté ma fille en voyant
les enfants nous ne le saurons très très
bonne idée qu'est ce que c'est que
casimir adore les merguez et les
brochettes
là bas je vais vous aider pour la
diriger puis tu es gentil interdiction
tiens je lis on prend ça oui mais
toi ou les orientations xala de
virages
comme ça comme ça abdellah chers amis
s'en vont me manquer ce qu'on serait
drôle oui en effet
moi je crois que cette fois on a à peu
près tout ancré à présent dénommée non
non je suis une avalanche est pas
d'accord me suis dit c'est pas possible
comme ça non la salle à manger ici la
cuisine canon et même en cas de non le
salon ici justement parce que les gens
rentrent obligatoirement puis tombe dans
le salon mais ça n'a pas de science
fiction
le salon est si bonne idée allons-y
allons-y nous verrons bien à nosy nous
verrons alors allons-y monde
sera mis
s'est occupée vous voyez pas
attention aux bieber à
la révolte
attendez
l'armoire à pharmacie c'est important
les épices voilà pour la lie à la casse
la
g league après après plus tard je range
rappelé voilà notre mission est
accomplie oui c'est très bien comme si
bien oui me remettra la
wii on rentre chez nous à grande échelle
nous envers
l'occident
j'ai les commentaires mon dieu
à nous d amy
[Musique]